avec Christine Durand oui déjà on est
très content et remercie évidemment les
électeurs qui ont qui se sont mobilisés
pour pour nous permettre de gagner on a
on a l'analyse c'est qu'on a fait un
gros travail de terrain une grosse
campagne de terrain de proximité
beaucoup de porte à pororte près 2500
quand même avec Christine et en ciblant
des axes prioritaires très trèsf qui
nous semblent essentiel à la population
et qui semble évidemment être conforté
par le score de ce soir l'emploi bien
évidemment le soutien au au plus
fragiles tout ce qui va être
infrastructure et puis la sécurité
puisqu'on avait évidemment des
problématiques de sécurité aussi à
défendre en matière de caserne par
exemple donc ce qui nous a conforté
c'est de voir que les choix qu'on avait
fait cette proximité on est aussi tous
les deux issu du monde de l'entreprise
on n'est pas des politiques
professionneles bah cette nouvelle voilà
cette nouvelle typologie peut-être d'lu
l'équipe qu'on formé avec nos deux
remplaçants va sembler semblit
correspondre en tout cas aux attentes
avec vous c'est la majorité
départementale qui a emporté c'est c'est
cet élan là qu'il faut voir oui oui il y
a un vrai élan au niveau départemental
il y a un vrai élan sur chaque canton
moi je suis content aussi sur la
circonscription du Bessin de voir que
brville orgilleuse l'emporté je suis
satisfait de voir qu'à wistream aussi
qu'à trévière qu'à comon les venté à
chaque fois c'était des enjeux
différents des candidats étaient contre
des des des candidats socialistes ou des
candidats Front national donc chaque
enjeu était bien particulier on s'est
tous battu on s'est tous aussi pas mal
entraidé c'est important puisque dans le
travail qu' aura faire pour la suite
c'était aussi important qu'on bâtisse j'
dirais presque déjà la la les
partenariats je je peux pas Michel
fricou qui retrouvver à wiream je
pourrais parler de Philippe Laurent et
de Véronique Martinez sur brvide
orgueilleux Jean-Pierre Richard à
trévière avec voilà donc déjà ces
partenariats qui nous permettront
d'avoir une cohérence territoriale
cohérence alors c'est une satisfaction
pour vous d'avoir écarté sur votre
gauche sur votre droite de de la même
manière c'était pas une satisfaction de
c'est une satisfaction de faire aboutir
un projet et puis de oui de de mener une
une équipe qui on pense qu'il va y avoir
un un vrai renouvellement et avec le
changement aussi avec les règles de la
parité il va y avoir un souffle aussi
nouveau important au niveau du conseil
général qui est important aussi hein
demain sur le Conseil départemental il y
aura la moitié de de de de d'élus qui
sont des femmes et c'est on pense que
c'est bien aussi il faut il faut de la
dynamique il faut la respiration
démocratique tout en restant dans une
majorité où on travaillera on apportera
chacun nos particularités